je crois que j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
célèbre je me laisse emmerder par
personne et surtout pas par les sommes
donne-moi ton portefeuille en douceur et
maintenant barquetoi d'ici au plus
vite j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait pour
survivre belle plage familles ont payé
beaucoup d'argent pour se débarrasser
des déchets tu connais rien de ma
de vie comment tu
t'appelles jenif tu ne me présentes pas
ton ami li je te présente mon père mes
amis m'appellent lie mais un gentleman
mature et séduisant comme vous peut
m'appeler et j'espère qu'on sera amené à
te voir souvent par
ici sa vie est vraiment en danger
elle manipule tu es juste la meilleure
chose qui me soit arrivée de toute ma
misérable pathétique vie elle contrôle
je le va je vous déclare mari et femme
ouais tu peux jouer le rôle de
l'innocente devant s mais moi je suis
pas d tu racontes de la merde sur moi je
ne vais pas regarder cette femme
détruire ma famille sans rien faire
elle n'a pas de conscience comme les
êtres humains normaux elle s'est mise
signataire autorisé sur tous les comptes
personnels de ton père au fond qu'est-ce
que tu sais vraiment de cette fille
c'est une criminelle condamnée nom de
Dieu ça
fait parce que mon mari il vaut des
millions j'aimerais fermer tous ces
comptes s'il vous plaît tous
désormais je sais quel genre de créature
tu es toute la réputation de ton père
les intérêts de l'entreprise familiale
tout est en jeu là mais toutes chose à
après tu sais et il est temps que tu
perd je crois que j'ai toujours rêvé
d'être
[Musique]
célèbre